Lucia:釉下彩吧
Lucia: It's underglaze.
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha:釉上釉下呀
Tasha: Overglaze or underglaze.
Jake:左上左下什么意思
Jake: What's overglaze and underglaze?
Lucia:哈哈哈就是两种上上彩的方式
Lucia: Hahaha, it's just two ways of glazing.
Tasha:上色工艺
Tasha: Coloring techniques.
Jake:是先上什么再上什么还是什么
Jake: Is it like what goes first and what goes next?
Tasha:嗯对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha:就相当于是你先把这个白色的烧出来
Tasha: It's like you first fire the white part.
Tasha:然后再把这个花纹涂上去
Tasha: Then you paint the pattern on.
Tasha:还是一开始就把花纹也涂好了
Tasha: Or you paint the pattern first.
Jake:哦哦怎么看呢
Jake: Oh, so how do you tell?
Tasha:然后再烧
Tasha: Then fire it again.
Tasha:嗯如果是釉上彩
Tasha: Well, if it's overglaze,
Tasha:如果是釉上彩的话
Tasha: if it's overglaze,
Tasha:其实吃着就有毒
Tasha: it's actually toxic to eat from.
Tasha:就对身体不好
Tasha: It's bad for your health.
Tasha:因为把这些矿物质原料吃进去
Tasha: Because you're ingesting those mineral materials.
Tasha:如果是釉下彩的话就更健康一点
Tasha: If it's underglaze, it's healthier.
Jake:如果是右下踩的话就更健康一点
Jake: If it's underfoot, it's healthier.
Tasha:但是他的花纹就没那么好看
Tasha: But the pattern isn't as pretty.
Tasha:颜色也不好看
Tasha: And the colors aren't nice either.
Jake:哦原来这个还是有
Jake: Oh, so there's still...
Lucia:感觉回到了我大学那个课上
Lucia: Feels like I'm back in my college class.
Tasha:他们出来了吗
Tasha: Did they come out?
Jake:给他们一点小任务
Jake: Give them a small task.
Jake:哎他们找到了
Jake: Oh, they found it.
Tasha:哦他找到了
Tasha: Oh, he found it.
Jake:嗯你好啊
Jake: Yeah, hi there.
Choiszt: 这是华为啊
Choiszt: This is Huawei.
Jake:这不华为吗
Jake: Isn't this Huawei?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:你们怎么找到的
Jake: How did you guys find it?
Jake:就是你们
Jake: It's you guys.
Jake:你们也不知道华为在哪
Jake: You don't even know where Huawei is.
Jake:还是嗯
Jake: Or, um...
Jake:那水平挺高
Jake: That's quite impressive.
Jake:走吧买
Jake: Let's go buy it.
Lucia:理论上说地球是圆的
Lucia: Theoretically, the Earth is round.
Lucia:对吧所以你只要往一个方向走
Lucia: Right, so if you keep walking in one direction,
Lucia:肯定能回到原点
Lucia: you'll eventually get back to the starting point.
Jake:可以能回到原点
Jake: Yeah, you can return to the starting point.
Jake:那确实哪都有华为
Jake: There's indeed Huawei everywhere.
Jake:找到下一个华为
Jake: Find the next Huawei.
Jack: 你这车有8s呀
Jack: Does your car have 8s?
Jake:倒着推
Jake: Push it backwards.
Jake:倒着推倒着推他就稳定
Jake: Push it backwards and it'll be stable.
Jake:这倒着推稳定
Jake: It's stable when pushed backwards.
Jake:完球
Jake: Game over.
Jake:哎烧烤套装
Jake: Hey, a barbecue set.
Jake:哎这
Jake: Hey, this...
Lucia:这给他抓回去放门口吧
Lucia: Let's grab it and put it by the door.
Jake:啊这是谁做的
Jake: Who made this?
Jake:纸小狗哈哈哈哈
Jake: A paper puppy, hahaha.
Lucia:他就趴在这个帐篷里
Lucia: It's just lying in this tent.
Tasha:为什么他搞了辆这么新的
Tasha: Why did he get such a new one?
Tasha:这辆这么旧
Tasha: And this one is so old.
Jake:对啊为什么
Jake: Yeah, why?
Jake:从哪拿的呀
Jake: Where did you get it from?
其他人：他停车场拿的
Others: He got it from the parking lot.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:讲究
Jake: Fancy.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Jake:咱不是有意思吗
Jake: Isn't it interesting?
Jake:咱们刚刚讨论过了
Jake: We just talked about this.
Nicous: 但是历史方法没拍
Nicous: But we didn't film the historical method.
Jake:没拍啊那就在今人的脑海里
Jake: Didn't film it? Then it's just in people's minds.
Jake:二锅头整点
Jake: Get some Erguotou.
Jake:二锅头可以
Jake: Erguotou is fine.
Choiszt: 真的吗
Choiszt: Really?
Lucia:真的吗
Lucia: Really?
Jake:真的吗真的吗
Jake: Really, really?
Choiszt: 死都不会喝一口红酒
Choiszt: I'd rather die than drink a sip of red wine.
Jake:为什么呀
Jake: Why?
Shure: 咋了
Shure: What's up?
Choiszt: 就是喝这个去了
Choiszt: Just went to drink this.
Choiszt: 吉利s哦
Choiszt: Lucky S, oh.
Jake:你什么时候喝的
Jake: When did you drink it?
Jake:过生日
Jake: On your birthday?
Choiszt: 过年
Choiszt: New Year's.
Jake:就是和出生一样在医院度过的生日
Jake: Like being born, spending your birthday in the hospital.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake:出生的时候一样在医院度过的生日
Jake: Spending your birthday in the hospital just like when you were born.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jack: 喝酒喝完就倒了啊
Jack: Drink and then pass out, huh?
Lucia:今天奇怪问答的含量好高啊
Lucia: Today’s strange questions content is really high.
Jake:对你过生日为什么去医院
Jake: Yeah, why did you go to the hospital on your birthday?
Lucia:什么情况下生日在医院上哈哈
Lucia: Under what circumstances would you spend your birthday in the hospital? Haha.
Jake:对哈哈
Jake: Yeah, haha.
Lucia:哎好像那天谢冰竹讲过
Lucia: Hey, I think Xie Bingzhu mentioned it that day.
Lucia:不过我有点忘记了
Lucia: But I kind of forgot.
Lucia:你是你是又喝了牛奶还是怎么回事
Lucia: Did you drink milk again or something?
Jake:是咱就买完了
Jake: Yeah, we just finished buying it.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia:还有乳糖不耐受那次吗
Lucia: Was it the lactose intolerance thing?
Jake:哦茉莉花茶
Jake: Oh, jasmine tea.
Lucia:sorry我错了
Lucia: Sorry, my bad.
Jake:为什么4瓶啊
Jake: Why 4 bottles?
Choiszt: 哈哈因为刚才我要拿6瓶
Choiszt: Haha, because I wanted to take 6 bottles earlier.
Tasha:我们为什么要逛这里啊
Tasha: Why are we shopping here?
Choiszt: 然后对号说大家不一定都喝哦
Choiszt: And then we said not everyone might drink.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:讲究讲究啊行行
Jake: It's quite particular, alright.
Choiszt: 4瓶就是随便随便喝
Choiszt: 4 bottles are just casual drinking.
Tasha:一只手两只手能拿下的程度
Tasha: Enough to carry with one or two hands.
Choiszt: 对
Choiszt: Exactly.
Choiszt: 两个有点少
Choiszt: Two is a bit too little.
Jake:他这边很多夹子耶
Jake: There are a lot of clips here.
Choiszt: 什么夹子
Choiszt: What clips?
Jake:不知道是什么东西
Jake: No idea what they are.
Jack: 哦防撞条
Jack: Oh, bumpers.
Jake:怎怎怎么就撞成这样了
Jake: How did it get so banged up?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:这不加还不知道撞成啥样了
Lucia: Without them, who knows how bad it would be.
Tasha:釉中彩
Tasha: Enamel paint.
Jake:还有釉中彩釉
Jake: There's also enamel paint.
Jack: 他们是不是自己选购
Jack: Are they choosing by themselves?
Jake:录着呢呵呵呵
Jake: We're recording, hehe.
Nicous: 我是要这个
Nicous: I want this.
Jake:没见过这些东西红牛
Jake: Never seen these things, Red Bull.
Nicous: 啥呀我们能用一次性餐具之类的吗
Nicous: Can we use disposable tableware?
Nicous: 不能不环保
Nicous: No, it's not eco-friendly.
Jake:不环保
Jake: Not eco-friendly.
Katrina: 那上次那个杯子打碎几个
Katrina: How many cups did we break last time?
Katrina: 那明天人更多了
Katrina: There will be more people tomorrow.
Katrina: 够用吗
Katrina: Will there be enough?
Jake:那就买几个杯子
Jake: Then let's buy a few cups.
Katrina: 哦好的
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Tasha:买几个杯子
Tasha: Buy a few cups.
Tasha:不是有一次性杯子吗
Tasha: Don't we have disposable cups?
Jake:呃买
Jake: Uh, buy them.
Jake:哈哈哈这个专业
Jake: Hahaha, this is professional.
Tasha:搁那上楼
Tasha: Put that upstairs.
Jack: 那afric是要被干死
Jack: Then Afric is gonna be doomed.
Jack: 我们的数据是在强迫的情况下
Jack: Our data is under coercion. 社会问题
Jake:哦那完了
Jake: Oh, that's bad.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:跑这么快
Jake: Running so fast
Jake:先上去吧这边的水
Jake: Let's go up first, the water here
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no
Jake:先上去吧我们
Jake: Let's go up first
Jake:哎呦我操
Jake: Oh my gosh
Jake:我把他给弄正
Jake: I'll straighten it out
Jack: 他好像不能往上推吧
Jack: It seems like it can't be pushed up, right?
Jake:但他怎么往下推了
Jake: But why did it get pushed down?
Jake:他哈哈哈
Jake: It hahaha
Lucia:对按说他应该是固定的
Lucia: Right, it should be fixed in place
Lucia:为了防止
Lucia: To prevent
Jake:你看你看你看
Jake: Look, look, look
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:那个就是从这坡上冲下去的时间
Lucia: That time it just rushed down the slope
Jake:是啊但是他他并不固定
Jake: Yeah, but it's not fixed
Jake:我们再试试啊哈哈
Jake: Let's try again, haha
Lucia: 不是后面也有人啊但是
Lucia: No, there are people behind us too, but
Jake:请请请一步
Jake: Please, please, move a step
Jake:对对对你看你看哎
Jake: Yes, yes, look, look, hey
Jake:现在好了现在好了对
Jake: Now it's okay, now it's okay, right
Jake:不受控制
Jake: Out of control
Jake:傲娇
Jake: So arrogant
Jack: 蓝莓
Jack: Blueberries
Jake:买
Jake: Buy
Lucia:啊我申请买一个蓝莓
Lucia: Ah, I apply to buy some blueberries
Jake:吃吃吃吃吃
Jake: Eat, eat, eat, eat, eat
Jake:买买买买
Jake: Buy, buy, buy, buy
Jake:九九块九九块9
Jake: 9.99, 9.99
Lucia:其中一种
Lucia: One of them
Jack: 蓝莓
Jack: Blueberries
Lucia:这种好像是9块9
Lucia: This one seems to be 9.99
Lucia:他在促销
Lucia: It's on sale
Jake:这个是15的
Jake: This one is 15
Lucia:所以大家选哪种
Lucia: So which one do you all choose?
Jake:这个是多少
Jake: How much is this?
Lucia:佳沃200 这是250克
Lucia: Jiawo 200, this is 250 grams
Lucia:那可能是这个吧
Lucia: Then it might be this one
Jake:19
Jake: 19
Lucia:这个会大一些
Lucia: This one is a bit bigger
Jake:这新加坡也19
Jake: It's also 19 in Singapore.
Jake:这这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Jake:19对19新币
Jake: 19, right? 19 Singapore dollars.
Lucia:这能打开吗
Lucia: Can this be opened?
Jake:这怎么吃
Jake: How do you eat this?
Tasha:这个
Tasha: This one.
Jack: 这是三室的这个啊
Jack: This is the one with three rooms.
Jack: 四个四个
Jack: Four, four.
Jake:这多少钱啊
Jake: How much is this?
Choiszt: 这你要买要熟一点
Choiszt: You need to buy this when it's ripe.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Choiszt: 正眼拍我
Choiszt: Take a proper shot of me.
Jake:丢回去丢回去
Jake: Throw it back, throw it back.
Jake:丢回去吧
Jake: Throw it back.
Jake:这个倒是性价比一般吧我感觉
Jake: The cost-performance ratio of this is just so-so, I think.
Jack: 确实不如在新加坡买吧
Jack: It's indeed not as good as buying in Singapore.
Jake:哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, true.
Jack: 新加坡榴莲应该很便宜
Jack: Durian in Singapore should be cheap.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly.
Jake:这些东西我觉得随便买到这
Jake: I think you can just buy these casually there.
Jake:我觉得不划算
Jake: I don't think it's worth it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:为什么这个在新加坡很便宜吗
Lucia: Why is it so cheap in Singapore?
Jake:嗯感觉是吧
Jake: Well, it feels like it, right?
Jake:那这个的话新加坡也是19块钱
Jake: So this one is also 19 dollars in Singapore.
Jake:这个的话可能
Jake: This one might be...
Jake:哎搞搞整不明白
Jake: Uh, I really don't get it.
Jack: 19块919块9新
Jack: 19.9, 19.9 Singapore dollars.
Jake:还19块9人民币
Jake: 19.9 yuan.
Jake:19块9新只有这东西
Jake: 19.9 Singapore dollars for this.
Lucia:十九块九新
Lucia: 19.9 Singapore dollars?
Jake:就这东西
Jake: Just this.
Jack: 19块9新哈哈
Jack: 19.9 Singapore dollars, haha.
Jack: 你现在买就等
Jack: If you buy it now, it's like...
Jack: 于打二折
Jack: getting an 80% discount.
Jake:大概就这么多
Jake: That's about it.
Jake:就这么多
Jake: Just this much.
Jake:那可能是什么奥丹尼
Jake: Then it might be something like Aldani.
Lucia:这么多十
Lucia: So much for ten...
Katrina: 必须
Katrina: Absolutely.
Jake:就是什么奥干那个
Jake: What was that organic thing?
Jake:就是什么
Jake: What is it?
Lucia:是organic蓝莓吗
Lucia: Is it organic blueberries?
Jake:对奥干那个
Jake: Yeah, organic ones.
Lucia:OK我就说这个
Lucia: Okay, I meant this one.
Lucia:不会吧差那么远
Lucia: No way, it's that different?
Lucia:那再来一盒吧哈哈
Lucia: Let's get another box then, haha.
Jake:但差不多也长这样
Jake: But they look pretty much the same.
Jake:我也吃不出来奥甘里克
Jake: I can't tell the difference between organic.
Jake:我也吃不出来这些东西
Jake: I can't tell these things apart.
Jake:我就觉得就是对
Jake: I just think they are the same.
Lucia:我也尝不出来
Lucia: I can't tell either.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:阶段就是5倍
Jake: The price difference is like 5 times.
Lucia:小宁真的有吓到我
Lucia: Xiaoning really surprised me.
Lucia:没想到啊
Lucia: I didn't expect that.
Lucia:我以为是在新加坡的价格
Lucia: I thought it was the price in Singapore.
Lucia:折成人民币
Lucia: Converted to RMB.
Jake:啊那没有
Jake: Oh, no, it's not.
Jake:这瓜真方
Jake: This watermelon is really square.
Jake:哎这盒干嘛的
Jake: Hey, what's this box for?
Jake:不知道是谁的是吧来一个
Jake: Don't know whose it is, right? Let's take one.
Jake:西瓜西瓜要吗
Jake: Watermelon, do you want some?
Tasha:西瓜不要
Tasha: No, I don't want watermelon.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:顾客你好
Jake: Hello, customer.
Jake:大促销
Jake: Big sale.
Jake:您还需要什么
Jake: Do you need anything else?
Tasha:计划采购榴莲了吗
Tasha: Are you planning to buy durians?
Jake:鸡蛋
Jake: Eggs.
Jake:哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Tasha:假的
Tasha: Just kidding.
Tasha:私人私人采购
Tasha: It's a private purchase.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Tasha:算了
Tasha: Never mind.
Jake:我都不记得表上写的什么
Jake: I don't even remember what's on the list.
Jake:回头找j人对一对
Jake: I'll check with J later.
Jake:我们p人就不管这些事了
Jake: We P people don't handle these things.
Jake:你这j还是p啊
Jake: Are you J or P?
Jack: j吧
Jack: J, right?
Jake:你忘了可还行
Jake: How could you forget that?
Jake:那看来是个p
Jake: Then it looks like it's a P.
Jake:哈哈哈看来是个p
Jake: Hahaha, it looks like it's a P.
Jake:哈哈哈你忘了可还行
Jake: Hahaha, how could you forget that?
Jake:那是p了
Jake: Then it's a P.
Jake:那真p了
Jake: It's really a P then.
Jack: 我是变过
Jack: I did change.
Jack: 我是变过啊
Jack: I did change, yeah.
Jake:行好
Jake: Alright.
Jack: 这是之前是ENTp和ENTJ反正
Jack: It used to be an ENTP and ENTJ anyway.
Jake:哦哦哦在中间里面
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, in between.
Jake:咋地
Jake: What's up?
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Jake:哎呀怎么这么浅
Jake: Oh no, why is it so shallow?
Jake:我扎着手了
Jake: I poked my hand.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn it.
Jake:对对我以为很深呢
Jake: Yeah, yeah, I thought it was deeper.
Jake:我一一组
Jake: Just my luck.
Jake:卧槽好疼
Jake: Damn, it hurts.
Jack: 我非常喜欢干这个
Jack: I really enjoy doing this.
Nicous: 小孩还喜欢吃冰糖
Nicous: Kids also like to eat rock candy.
Jake:是悄悄吃一个
Jake: Yeah, secretly eating one.
Jake:吃个枣吃个冰糖
Jake: Eating a date, eating rock candy.
Jack: 我草刘帅
Jack: Damn it, Choiszt.
Lucia:那我吃了
Lucia: Then I'll eat it.
Lucia:万一他们把我抓起来的
Lucia: What if they catch me?
Lucia:话你可要把我保释出来啊
Lucia: You have to bail me out then.
Jake:哈哈哈这个你
Jake: Hahaha, you...
Jake:你这是有迷彩色的
Jake: You have camouflage.
Jake:就是看不出来摄像头
Jake: So they can't see the camera.
Jake:因为这个颜色是差不多的哦
Jake: Because the color is almost the same.
Jack: 给他点冰糖不错
Jack: Give him some rock candy, it's good.
Jack: 可以吃一口
Jack: He can have a bite.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Lucia:不行先吃枣吧
Lucia: No, let's eat the date first.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:要不然话就不甜了
Lucia: Otherwise, it won't taste sweet.
Jake:单斤冰糖
Jake: Single crystal rock candy.
Tasha:我没有要买
Tasha: I didn't mean to buy it.
Tasha:我只是觉得这个虾怎么这么大
Tasha: I just think this shrimp is so big.
Jake:这怎么有这么多种枣
Jake: How can there be so many kinds of dates?
Jake:品一品啊品一品
Jake: Taste it, taste it.
Jake:为什么有这么多种枣
Jake: Why are there so many kinds of dates?
Jake:这个好吃
Jake: This one is delicious.
Jake:让我吃一个
Jake: Let me have one.
Jack: 它比小枣好吃
Jack: It's tastier than the small dates.
Jack: 但不知道他这这个
Jack: But I don't know about this one...
Jack: 我感觉这个价钱不是很好
Jack: I feel like the price isn't great.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Jack: 我爸连新疆都带回来过的枣哇这个又大又好
Jack: My dad even brought back dates from Xinjiang, and they're big and good.
Jake:去头红虾
Jake: Headless red shrimp.
Choiszt: 咱们今天晚上吃啥
Choiszt: What are we having for dinner tonight?
Choiszt: 提前预备着
Choiszt: Let's prepare in advance.
Jake:咱今晚上吃啥呀
Jake: What are we having tonight?
Jack: 外卖吧
Jack: Let's order takeout.
Lucia:外卖吧
Lucia: Let's order takeout.
Jake:麦当劳吧麦当劳吧
Jake: How about McDonald's? McDonald's.
Jake:烧烤不行
Jake: Barbecue won't work.
Jake:烧烤你得啥
Jake: What do you need for barbecue?
Jake:今今天你得一点吃到
Jake: Today, you won't get to eat until late.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈昨天
Choiszt: Haha, yesterday...
Choiszt: 昨天就这个
Choiszt: Yesterday, it was the same.
Choiszt: 这个开麦吗
Choiszt: Is this mic on?
Jack: 现在才4点08
Jack: It's only 4:08 now.
Jake:回来还有事呢
Jake: There are still things to do when we get back.
Jake:没空给你烤
Jake: No time to grill for you.
Jake:或者你来烤
Jake: Or you can grill.
Jake:你没啥事
Jake: You have nothing to do.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:谢谢大哥
Lucia: Thank you, big brother.
Jake:我们我们雇了个主厨挺好
Jake: We hired a head chef, it's pretty good.
Jake:主厨您还需要什么
Jake: Chef, do you need anything else?
Jake:谢谢啊晚饭结束了
Jake: Thanks, dinner is over.
Jack: 好我们俩晚饭已经吃过了
Jack: Alright, we already had dinner.
Jack: 今天你们自己安排
Jack: You guys arrange it yourself tonight.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:咱晚饭吃完了
Jake: We finished dinner.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake:这个
Jake: This
Jake:晚上晚上的糕点
Jake: Evening pastries
Jake:没有晚上我们要做糕点了
Jake: No, tonight we need to make pastries
Jake:晚上我们要做很多很多很多很多糕点
Jake: Tonight we need to make lots and lots of pastries
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Choiszt: 这样装饰的好看一点
Choiszt: This decoration looks a bit nicer
Jake:你得换个
Jake: You need to change
Jake:你得换个头发
Jake: You need to change your hairstyle
Jake:别人换个衣服
Jake: Others change their clothes
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:长沙出来的又
Jake: The ones from Changsha
其他人：好好吃啊
Others: It's so delicious
其他人：你不觉得吗
Others: Don't you think so?
Jake:今晚
Jake: Tonight
Jake:今晚吃泡面吧
Jake: Let's have instant noodles tonight
Jake:也不是不行
Jake: It's not a bad idea
Lucia:对作为方便面来说味还可以
Lucia: Yeah, for instant noodles, it tastes okay
Jack: 那肯定是作为方便面
Jack: Of course, for instant noodles
Jack: 但是绝对是方便面里的
Jack: But it's definitely top-tier instant noodles
Jake:那
Jake: Well
Jack: 给你们摇来了我们的金主啊
Jack: Brought you our sponsor
Jake:今晚吃方便面吧
Jake: Let's have instant noodles tonight
Jake:哈哈哈牛排
Jake: Hahaha steak
Jake:牛牛排方便面牛排方便面
Jake: Steak instant noodles, steak instant noodles
Lucia:牛排方便面
Lucia: Steak instant noodles
Jake:牛排方便面怎么样
Jake: How about steak instant noodles?
其他人：不如麦当劳啊啊
Others: Not as good as McDonald's
Jake:主厨说要吃麦当劳
Jake: The chef says we should eat McDonald's
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:主厨决定要吃麦当劳
Jake: The chef has decided to eat McDonald's
Jake:我们的主厨主厨我们的主厨
Jake: Our chef, our chef, our chef
Jake:决定吃麦当劳
Jake: Decided to eat McDonald's
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Jake:他也吃麦当劳
Jake: He eats McDonald's too
Nicous: 是谁提的麦当劳啊
Nicous: Who suggested McDonald's?
Jake:麦当劳是他提的
Jake: McDonald's was his idea
Tasha:麦麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burgers
Jake:对就是他
Jake: Yeah, it was him
Jake:昨天一直在唱麦当劳汉堡
Jake: He was singing about McDonald's burgers all night
Jake:然后告诉我一晚上150
Jake: Then told me it costs 150 for a night
Jake:我靠我这
Jake: Oh my god, I...
Jake:哈哈哈建立了一些不可磨灭的联系
Jake: Hahaha, we've established some unbreakable bonds.
Jack: 哈哈可真好吃
Jack: Haha, it's really delicious.
Jack: 回去回去要买一个放我宿舍
Jack: I'm going to buy one to put in my dorm when I go back.
Jake:那你现在买
Jake: Then buy it now.
Jack: 现在买我还得拎回去
Jack: If I buy it now, I'll have to carry it back.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha:到底啥味啊
Tasha: What does it actually taste like?
Jake:但是哦好吧
Jake: But, oh well, okay.
Jake:就是你
Jake: It's just that...
Jake:你看中的品种不在乎这个价钱
Jake: The kind you're interested in doesn't care about the price.
Tasha:怎么我们这么大一群人
Tasha: How come there's such a big group of us...
Tasha:就一辆购物车都没有呢
Tasha: And we don't even have a shopping cart?
Tasha:要买一瓶鲜牛奶
Tasha: I need to buy a bottle of fresh milk.
Jake:车呢
Jake: Where's the cart?
Lucia:曾经我们有一辆购物车
Lucia: We used to have a shopping cart.
Jake:那我们的车是不是落了呀
Jake: Did we leave our cart somewhere?
Jake:车丢了我们车丢了
Jake: The cart is lost! Our cart is lost!
Jake:我他妈找啊卧槽
Jake: Damn it, I'm looking for it, damn.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:不是吧那根线好像很值钱的样子
Lucia: No way, that wire looks pretty expensive.
Lucia: 我不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia:就是对吧
Lucia: Right?
Jake:就是是确实
Jake: Yeah, it really is.
Jake:但是吧在哪啊在哪
Jake: But, where is it? Where is it?
Lucia:在哪啊
Lucia: Where is it?
Jake:好我们我们来
Jake: Alright, let's...
Jake:复盘从吃枣开始
Jake: Let's review from the time we started eating dates.
Lucia:你现在能把这个视频数据调出来
Lucia: Can you pull up the video data now?
Lucia:看一眼吗
Lucia: To take a look?
Jake:哈哈哈现在不能得有一个笔记本
Jake: Hahaha, not now. We need a notebook.
Jake:你找找我从这开始复盘
Jake: You look for it, I'll start the review from here.
Jake:哪来的呀
Jake: Where did it come from?
Jack: 在卖橙子那
Jack: From the orange seller.
Jake:卖橙子那丢了这么早就丢了
Jake: From the orange seller? It got lost so early?
Jake:他怎么又
Jake: How come...
Tasha:我想吃面
Tasha: I want to eat noodles.
Jake:那你买啊
Jake: Then buy some.
Tasha:我只想尝尝
Tasha: I just want to taste it.
Jake:你买
Jake: You buy it.
Jake:那你去吃
Jake: Then go eat.
Jake:买别别跑别跑别跑
Jake: Buy it, don't run, don't run, don't run.
Jake:我们这进度不行啊
Jake: We're not making any progress here.
Jake:呵
Jake: Huh.
Jake:这是拿的啥呀
Jake: What did you get?
Jake:李子李子啊
Jake: Plums, plums, huh?
Choiszt: 这是不是要称啊
Choiszt: Do we need to weigh this?
Lucia:他说楼下称
Lucia: He said weigh it downstairs.
Lucia:我刚问了
Lucia: I just asked.
Jake:咋的
Jake: What?
Lucia:咱咱这平均下来一人才吃俩
Lucia: On average, each person only gets two.
Lucia:不会拉肚子的
Lucia: We won't get diarrhea.
Jack: 这车就这么点东西
Jack: This cart has so little stuff.
Jake:对啊怕丢了
Jake: Yeah, afraid it'll get lost.
Jake:你们这你们球丢完了哈哈哈
Jake: You guys, you lost all your balls, hahaha.
Lucia:这是to do list 吗
Lucia: Is this a to-do list?
Jake:啊哈哈哈啊
Jake: Ah hahaha.
Jake:我看看有多少自由发挥了
Jake: Let me see how much free play we have.
Jake:哈哈哈这个是也挺自由啊
Jake: Hahaha, this is quite free too.
Jake:哈哈哈啊还有吗
Jake: Hahaha, is there more?
Jake:没有哦那这些是干嘛的哈哈
Jake: No? Then what are these for, haha.
Jake:哎行行行走吧走吧哈哈
Jake: Alright, alright, let's go, let's go, haha.
Jake:怕嘉宾们吃不惯没鸭脖的东西
Jake: Afraid the guests won't get used to it without duck neck.
Jake:你有几个朋友
Jake: How many friends do you have?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:虽远必诛
Lucia: "Though distant, must be punished."
Lucia:有朋自远方来
Lucia: "Friends coming from afar."
Lucia:虽远必诛
Lucia: "Though distant, must be punished."
Jake:虽远必诛
Jake: "Though distant, must be punished."
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is this?
Lucia:这是一种新新的弱智吗
Lucia: Is this a new kind of stupidity?
Jake:哈哈哈什么呀
Jake: Hahaha, what?
Nicous: 你竟然没看过阿巴斯
Nicous: You haven't seen Abbas?
Jake:我不知道抖音吗
Jake: I don't know, TikTok?
Jake:阿巴斯印度歌
Jake: Abbas, the Indian singer.
Nicous: 你看评论区
Nicous: Check the comments.
Jake:阿巴斯你知道吗
Jake: Abbas, you know him?
Jake:但丁真去过地狱
Jake: Dante really went to hell.
Jake:但音准不一定
Jake: But not sure about the pitch.
Lucia:神经病
Lucia: Crazy.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Nicous: 没看过阿巴斯
Nicous: Haven't seen Abbas
Lucia:如果你来我家的话
Lucia: If you come to my house
Lucia:我会请你吃槟榔羹
Lucia: I'll treat you to betel nut soup
Jake:哦哦哦为什么
Jake: Oh oh oh, why?
Jake:这这阿巴斯是什么
Jake: What is this Abbas?
Jake:傻屌啊
Jake: Silly
Katrina: 然后大家都在他评论区里说一些中文
Katrina: And then everyone is saying something in Chinese in his comment section
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Nicous: 你觉得一锅粥呢
Nicous: What do you think of a pot of porridge?
Jake:他在学中文是吧
Jake: He's learning Chinese, right?
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay
Choiszt: 阿巴斯你什么时候来北京
Choiszt: Abbas, when are you coming to Beijing?
Choiszt: 我骑着你去爬长城
Choiszt: I'll ride with you to climb the Great Wall
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:走吧走吧走
Jake: Let's go, let's go
Nicous: 阿巴斯 你记住是金子的总会发光
Nicous: Abbas, remember, gold always shines
Nicous: 但但是你是老铁
Nicous: But you're an old buddy
Lucia:但是你是老铁
Lucia: But you're an old buddy
Jake:哈哈巴基斯坦老铁是吧
Jake: Hahaha, a Pakistani buddy, right?
Jake:好好好行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, fine, fine
Shure: 让我带你去
Shure: Let me take you
Jake:看着不错
Jake: Looks good
Jake:这超市也看得见
Jake: You can see this in the supermarket too
Jake:不错哈哈哈哈是
Jake: Not bad, hahaha, yes
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Choiszt: 人家那个美食节目
Choiszt: That food show
Choiszt: 就是什么15分钟不限时
Choiszt: It's like, 15 minutes, no time limit
Choiszt: 15分钟不限量
Choiszt: 15 minutes, no quantity limit
Choiszt: 抢购这个东西就直接往车里呵
Choiszt: People just rush and load stuff directly into the car
Jake:对我呵呵
Jake: Yeah, hehe
Jake:就直接多米诺呵呵呵
Jake: Just like Domino's, hehe
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:你不是j人吗
Jake: Aren't you a J person?
Jake:嗯那你的菠萝哪来了
Jake: Then where did you get the pineapple?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Choiszt: 在我计划之内
Choiszt: It's part of my plan
Jack: 哈哈本就在计划着
Jack: Hahaha, it was planned
Jake:本就在计划啊
Jake: It was planned, huh
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then
Jake:我在琢磨这是个p车
Jake: I'm wondering if this is a P car.
Jake:这是个j车
Jake: This is a J car.
Jake:结果好像并不是这样
Jake: But it doesn't seem like it.
Jake:p车p车和j车
Jake: P car, P car, and J car.
Jake:那j车上面还挺丰富
Jake: The J car is quite loaded.
Jake:p车还没啥东西
Jake: The P car doesn't have much.
Jake:就是丢了这个很p
Jake: It's just that this thing is very P.
Lucia:就丢了
Lucia: Just lost it.
Jake:哈哈哈丢了这个东西很p
Jake: Hahaha, this thing is very P.
Jake:好推啊
Jake: It's easy to push.
Jake:咱是不是又少了个人啊
Jake: Are we missing someone again?
Choiszt: 他在等那个拉面
Choiszt: He's waiting for the ramen.
Jake:他啥吃拉面去了
Jake: He went to get ramen?
Jake:那他知道我们下来了吗
Jake: Does he know we came down?
Jake:那我们上去吧哈哈
Jake: Let's go back up, haha.
Jake:怎么上去
Jake: How do we go up?
Jake:那边上去
Jake: Over there.
Jake:好吃吗
Jake: Is it good?
Jake:好吃
Jake: It's good.
Jake:旺仔这里有吗
Jake: Is there any Wangzai here?
Katrina: 他说在一楼
Katrina: He said it's on the first floor.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:问问一楼是不是
Jake: Ask if it's on the first floor.
Jake:他说在二楼哈哈哈
Jake: He said it's on the second floor, haha.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:我看到了我看到了我看到了我看到了
Jake: I see it, I see it, I see it, I see it.
Katrina: 问一下他要多少
Katrina: Ask him how much he wants.
Jake:哦问叉叉是吗
Jake: Oh, ask Jack, right?
Jake:还是嗯
Jake: Or, um.
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Jake:旺仔牛奶要几瓶
Jake: How many bottles of Wangzai milk?
Tasha:够了
Tasha: That's enough.
Tasha:灯还亮吗
Tasha: Are the lights still on?
Jake:亮着行
Jake: They're on, it's fine.
Tasha:哎如果今天晚上吃的话就要两瓶
Tasha: Hey, if we're eating tonight, we need two bottles.
Tasha:明天如果还做的话还要两瓶
Tasha: If we're cooking tomorrow, we need two more.
Jake:那再来两瓶
Jake: Then get two more.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:今天晚上大家要一起吃是吗
Tasha: Everyone's eating together tonight, right?
Jake:吃
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:好贵啊 5块8一瓶
Tasha: So expensive, 5.8 yuan per bottle.
Jake:啊这么贵哈哈
Jake: Ah, so expensive, haha.
Tasha:没看错吧
Tasha: Did I see it wrong?
Jake:啊为什么
Jake: Ah, why?
Tasha:哦这两个是一样大的
Tasha: Oh, these two are the same size.
Tasha:你来算这两个哪个划算
Tasha: You calculate which of these two is more cost-effective.
Jake:这个不一样的
Jake: These are different.
Jake:这这这净含量不一样哎
Jake: The net content is different, right?
Jake:对吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha:你算呀
Tasha: You calculate it.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Jake:你你你给你能给我一个这东西我来算
Jake: You, you, you, can you give me this thing so I can calculate?
Tasha:12块钱这个就是3块钱一罐
Tasha: 12 yuan, this one is 3 yuan per can.
Jake:这多少升啊
Jake: How many liters is this?
Tasha:145
Tasha: 145.
Jake:看不出来
Jake: I can't tell.
Jake:你咋看出来的
Jake: How can you tell?
Tasha:这写着呢啊
Tasha: It's written here.
Jake:哦哦哦对不起
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, sorry.
Jake:那我们来算一算
Jake: Let's calculate it.
Tasha:我靠你不要这么依赖
Tasha: Oh my god, don't be so reliant.
Jake:那得依赖100多少
Jake: We have to rely on it, how much is it, 100...
Jake:145*4*4总共580升
Jake: 145*4*4, total 580 liters.
Jake:11块12块钱
Jake: 11 yuan, 12 yuan.
Jake:多少
Jake: How much?
Jake:哈哈 540升是吧
Jake: Haha, 540 liters, right?
Jake:然后这个是
Jake: And then this one is...
Tasha:5.8
Tasha: 5.8.
Jake:245 是4490是吧
Jake: 245, so 4490, right?
Jake:490 哦
Jake: 490, oh.
Tasha: 为什么是490
Tasha: Why is it 490?
Jake:因为成了两个 5点
Jake: Because it became two, 5 point...
Tasha:可是这不是单罐吗
Tasha: But isn't this a single can?
Jake:5.8/245
Jake: 5.8/245.
Tasha: 245 哪个便宜
Tasha: 245, which one is cheaper?
Jake:他便宜他便宜
Jake: This one is cheaper, it's cheaper.
Tasha:他便宜
Tasha: It's cheaper.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha:走那就拿4个
Tasha: Let's go, let's take four.
Tasha:这个就行了
Tasha: This will do.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha:走
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:哎哎呀哎呀哎呀对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Tasha:不是对不起就可以弥补的
Tasha: "Sorry" isn't enough to make up for it.
Jake:那怎么办
Jake: Then what should I do?
Tasha:哈哈没想好呢
Tasha: Haha, I haven't thought about it yet.
Jake:好想想
Jake: Okay, think about it.
Tasha:经过我们严密严整的计算
Tasha: After our thorough and precise calculations...
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Jake:加餐呢
Jake: Extra meal, right?
Jake:对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, this is it.
Jake:稍微便宜
Jake: A bit cheaper.
Jake:能便宜个一毛半
Jake: Can save around 1.5 cents.
Jake:人民币人民币哈哈哈
Jake: In RMB, in RMB, hahaha.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is this?
Jake:啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah.
Jake:可以OK
Jake: Alright, okay.
Jake:呵呵走吧
Jake: Haha, let's go.
Jake:这还有发票还
Jake: There's still an invoice here.
Shure: 那男的都能
Shure: All the men can...
Shure: 但是国外报销他走发票这一套
Shure: But abroad, they use invoices for reimbursement.
Jake:都不走都不走
Jake: They don't, they don't.
Lucia:都不走
Lucia: They don't.
Jake:对都不走
Jake: Right, they don't.
Lucia:发票啊
Lucia: Invoices, huh?
Jake:发票都不走
Jake: They don't use invoices.
Shure: 他走什么走
Shure: Then what do they use?
Lucia:国内一般都有
Lucia: Usually, domestically, they do.
Jake:走信任
Jake: They go by trust.
Shure: 真的呀
Shure: Really?
Jake:走走预算报账啊
Jake: They go by budget reimbursement.
Lucia:说到这个既然快递都到的差不多了
Lucia: Speaking of which, since most of the deliveries have arrived...
Lucia:可以报销一下吗
Lucia: Can we get reimbursed?
Jake:可可以啊
Jake: Yes, you can.
Jake:可以发账单嘛
Jake: You can send the bill.
Lucia:好的我怎么发呀那就
Lucia: Alright, how do I send it then?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:对三三全是33M对
Jake: Right, three-three, all are 33M, right.
Lucia:那我怎么发呀
Lucia: So how should I send it?
Lucia:难道截图发你吗
Lucia: Should I screenshot and send it to you?
Jake:我我回头弄个Excel吧
Jake: I'll make an Excel later.
Tasha:我要弄吗
Tasha: Should I make one?
Tasha:哎都大家都要弄Excel是吗
Tasha: Oh, does everyone need to make an Excel?
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:你们往那边写对
Jake: You guys write it over there, right.
Shure: 他弄一个然后
Shure: He makes one and then...
Jake:干过啊干过
Jake: Done it before, done it before.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:共享Excel
Jake: Share the Excel.
Jake:干过是吧哈哈
Jake: Done it before, right? Haha.
其他人：我操哈哈哈
Others: Oh my God, hahaha.
其他人：有点破防了哈哈哈
Others: Kind of breaking down, haha.
Lucia:这这个茶很好喝
Lucia: This tea is really good.
Jake:张一元你懂吗你懂吗你懂我吗你懂吗
Jake: Zhang Yiyuan, do you understand? Do you understand? Do you understand me?
其他人：你可能还不太懂哈哈
Others: You might not quite understand yet, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:可能下个月让你懂一懂
Jake: Maybe next month you'll understand.
Lucia:我们要不要来一盒
Lucia: Should we get a box?
Lucia:请嘉宾喝
Lucia: To serve the guests.
Lucia:319哈哈哈
Lucia: 319, hahaha.
Jake:多少钱这个
Jake: How much is this?
Jake: 好嘞哈哈哈
Jake: Alright, hahaha.
Shure: 60新币啊哈哈哈 60新
Shure: 60 Singapore dollars, haha. 60 SGD.
Lucia:这应该是一个北京的老字号好像
Lucia: This should be an old brand from Beijing, I think.
Jake:没有灯
Jake: No light.
Jack: 回到中国什么东西一除五就感觉没有那么贵
Jack: When you go back to China, divide everything by five and it doesn't seem as expensive.
Jake:那确实那确实
Jake: That's true, that's true.
Shure: 那谁的线掉了
Shure: Whose cord fell off?
Lucia:他再多待几天回新加坡就该乘5了
Lucia: If he stays a few more days, when he returns to Singapore, it'll be multiplied by five.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:是我的是我的
Lucia: It's mine, it's mine.
Jake:生命线哈哈哈
Jake: Lifeline, hahaha.
Jake:生命线生命线
Jake: Lifeline, lifeline.
Lucia:OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Tasha:结账吧
Tasha: Let's check out.
Lucia:我给眼镜续个命哈
Lucia: Let me recharge my glasses.
Jake:结账走
Jake: Let's check out and go.
Lucia:他现在没灭吧
Lucia: It's not off now, right?
Jake:没灭没灭得
Jake: No, it's not off.
Jake:他开的啊
Jake: It's on.
Jake:很对很对
Jake: That's right, that's right.
Shure: 需要外卖购物一点好
Shure: We need to order some takeout.
Jake:有些酒
Jake: Some alcohol.
Jake:哪些酒
Jake: Which alcohol?
Shure: 所有的酒都没有
Shure: There's no alcohol at all.
Jake:所有酒都没有
Jake: No alcohol at all.
Jake:那就买吧
Jake: Then let's buy some.
Jake:你要不现在就买吧
Jake: Why don't you buy it now?
Shure: 也行我现在买
Shure: Okay, I'll buy it now.
Lucia:哎这里面还有一
Lucia: Hey, there's a
Lucia:个充电宝
Lucia: power bank inside.
Tasha:it's me啊
Tasha: It's me.
Jake:你要不也插上生命线
Jake: Why don't you plug it into the lifeline?
Tasha:哎那个人招手让我们过去呢
Tasha: Hey, that person is waving us over.
Lucia:一会再插
Lucia: Plug it in later.
Jake:他一直不给我
Jake: He never gives it to me.
Jake:就是他自
Jake: It's just that he
Jake:己人不是
Jake: is not one of us.
Tasha:哎呀我不好意思让你帮我拿
Tasha: I'm embarrassed to ask you to hold it for me.
Jake:丢哪了
Jake: Where did it go?
Jack: 应该在刚刚吃那
Jack: It should be where we just ate.
Jack: 他为啥给你
Jack: Why did he give it to you?
Jake:因为他要插线
Jake: Because he wants to plug it in.
Lucia:吓死了我刚还以为这根线找不到了呢
Lucia: I was so scared, I thought we lost this cord.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:找不到了要赔多少钱
Tasha: How much would we have to pay if we lose it?
Jake:不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Lucia:没有考虑过这种问题
Lucia: Never thought about that.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:就一些很难想的问题我们就不想了
Jake: We just don't think about difficult questions like that.
Jake:这车得推出来的
Jake: This car needs to be pushed out.
Jake:这个这个这个
Jake: This, this, this.
Jake:能有能能能对
Jake: Can it, can it, can it work?
Jake:专门给他弄一个
Jake: Make one just for him.
Jake:那抱着吧
Jake: Then hold it.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Tasha:麦当劳汉堡
Tasha: McDonald's burger.
Jake:你搁新加坡抽你两鞭子
Jake: I'll whip you twice in Singapore.
Jake:哈哈哈不要开发票
Jake: Hahaha, don't issue an invoice.
Jake:就直接预算
Jake: Just budget directly.
Jake:直接打钱
Jake: Directly transfer the money.
Jack: 鞭刑
Jack: Whipping punishment.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:抽两鞭子就只要一鞭子可能不用
Jake: Two whips, maybe just one whip isn't necessary.
Jake:两鞭子
Jake: Two whips.
Jack: 没有什么喂哺的方式
Jack: There's no way to avoid it.
Jake:呃你可以怀孕
Jake: Uh, you can get pregnant.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jack: 罚款吗呃
Jack: Fine, then maybe a fine?
Jake:罚款也会罚
Jake: Yeah, there will be a fine.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jack: 罚款并鞭刑
Jack: A fine and whipping.
Jack: 还是罚款或者
Jack: Or just a fine?
Jake:不好说
Jake: Hard to say.
Jake:就是他
Jake: If he...
Jake:他要判你鞭刑他就是跑不掉了
Jake: If he sentences you to whipping, there's no escape.
Jake:你给多少钱都得鞭
Jake: No matter how much you pay, you still get whipped.
Jack: 哦那比如像这种
Jack: Oh, what about something like this...
Jack: 我忘了无心之过哎
Jack: I forgot, it was an honest mistake.
Jake:那就罚款
Jake: Then just a fine.
Jake:再你再无心几次就抽鞭子对
Jake: But if you make a few more mistakes, then it's the whip.
Lucia:这个玻璃杯好危险啊
Lucia: This glass cup is so dangerous.
Jake:啊已经碎了
Jake: Ah, it's already broken.
Lucia:啊没有没有
Lucia: Ah, no, no.
Jack: 这个这么搁真的没问题吗
Jack: Is it really okay to put it like this?
Lucia: 拿着吧反正就几个袋子
Lucia: Just hold it, there are only a few bags.
Lucia: 这么多人
Lucia: So many people.
Lucia:哎呦喂
Lucia: Oh my!
Jake:那条条是谁的
Jake: Whose stuff is that?
Lucia:拿着
Lucia: Take it.
Lucia:防止他那个闪
Lucia: To prevent it from flashing.
Lucia:呃我们都装好了
Lucia: Uh, we packed everything.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Jack: 哔哩哔哩干杯
Jack: Bilibili, cheers.
Jake:干杯干杯
Jake: Cheers, cheers.
Jake:走怎么走
Jake: How do we go?
Jake:先充值再购物
Jake: First top-up, then shop.
Jake:咱也没充值
Jake: We didn't recharge.
Jake:全给你们车
Jake: All for your car.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:东西全给他们车
Jake: Everything is for their car.
Jake:然后我们轻松的走
Jake: And then we leave easily.
Nicous: 你们是不是要拿
Nicous: Are you going to take it?
Nicous: 拿出去对着你们拿一个
Nicous: Take it out and give it to them?
Lucia:什么杯子
Lucia: What cup?
Shure: 不是这两个拿
Shure: Not those two.
Shure: OK车就不用拿
Shure: Okay, no need to take the car.
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye, bye bye.
Jake:关了吧
Jake: Turn it off.
Jake:哎上车就关
Jake: Hey, turn it off once we're in the car.
Jake:好上车关好
Jake: Alright, turn it off once we're in the car.
Tasha:stale hour for no
Tasha: stale hour for no
Jake:style
Jake: style
Jake:powerful什么东西
Jake: powerful what?
Tasha:no哈哈哈
Tasha: no hahaha
Jake:no no
Jake: no no
Jake:看看那
Jake: look at that
Tasha:还是我们4个
Tasha: Still the four of us.
Jake:四爹啊我佛
Jake: Four dads, oh my Buddha.
Lucia:中文语式打乱并不影响阅读
Lucia: The syntax is messed up but still readable.
Jake:呵呵呵购物十付满一二8一元元一啊
Jake: Haha, shopping ten pay full one two 8 one yuan yuan one ah
Jake:我靠满一二8元
Jake: Damn, spend 128 yuan.
Jake:一分钱够洗衣凝珠
Jake: One cent is enough for laundry detergent pods.
Jake:哦不他是这样
Jake: Oh no, it's like this.
Lucia:他送了一个
Lucia: He gave one.
Jake:他是他是
Jake: He is, he is.
Jake:购物首付满821元
Jake: Shopping first payment full 821 yuan.
Jake:就这个是对的
Jake: This is correct.
Lucia: 哈哈满121元
Lucia: Haha, spend 121 yuan.
Tasha:他要从这边开始看
Tasha: He should start from here.
Jake:那12828 哈哈哈
Jake: Then 12828 hahaha.
Tasha:为什么不分开买两个128呢
Tasha: Why not split it into two 128s?
Lucia:哎有道理
Lucia: Oh, makes sense.
Lucia:但反正
Lucia: But anyway,
Lucia:他当时确实给咱送了一盒洗衣凝珠
Lucia: He did give us a box of laundry detergent pods at that time.
Jake:哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, that's what happened.
Lucia:对我们应该结完128就
Lucia: Yeah, we should have settled it after spending 128.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:好走吧这个就放那吧
Jake: Alright, let's go, just leave it there.
Jake:多点会员购物满50元免费送的
Jake: Members who shop for more than 50 yuan get free delivery.
Jake:字体为什么能做成这个样子
Jake: Why is the font like this?
Lucia:我也想问
Lucia: I was wondering that too.
Jake:他为了省纸是吧
Jake: Is it to save paper?
Lucia:那那个满字为什么那么大
Lucia: Then why is the "满" character so big?
Jake:满可能他省不了太挤了
Jake: Maybe they couldn't save space, it was too cramped.
Jake:养乐多
Jake: Yakult.
Tasha:那不是养乐多
Tasha: That's not Yakult.
Tasha:那是UEC
Tasha: That's UEC.
Jake:哦不一样
Jake: Oh, it's different.
Tasha:假的
Tasha: It's fake.
Jake:呵呵呵山寨
Jake: Haha, it's a knockoff.
Jake:我打个车
Jake: I'll call a cab.
Tasha:好看你要不要买
Tasha: Looks good, do you want to buy it?
Tasha:你这也是十十个色
Tasha: You have ten colors here too.
Jake:呵呵确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Lucia:这这是毛的吧
Lucia: Is this wool?
Lucia:不是不是是是那普通的夏天的衣服
Lucia: No, no, it's just regular summer clothing.
Lucia:没摸出来但应该不是棉不像纯棉
Lucia: I can't tell by touch, but it doesn't feel like pure cotton.
Jack: 哎呀所以所以你的打车费上他也能报
Jack: Oh man, so they even reimburse your cab fare?
Jack: 无条件信任
Jack: Unconditional trust.
Jake:就就就我报个数字然后打钱就是这样
Jake: Yeah, I just report a number and they send the money, that's it.
Jack: 居然无条件信任
Jack: Unconditional trust, really?
Tasha:啊哎呀
Tasha: Ah, oh wow.
Jack: 那建议把我去首都的车车车费也报了
Jack: Then I suggest they reimburse my fare to the capital city too.
Jake:对这个
Jake: Yeah, that...
Jake:总之就是算个总账拿个清单
Jake: Anyway, just do the overall accounting and get a detailed list.
Jake:没想到了
Jake: Didn't see that coming.
Jake:就是没想到这层了对对对
Jake: Yeah, didn't think of that, exactly.
Jake:后天再想这一层
Jake: Think about that the day after tomorrow.
Lucia:没事他可以到了机场
Lucia: It's okay, he can get to the airport.
Lucia:然后随机选择一个目的地
Lucia: And then randomly pick a destination.
Jake:对对是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes, that's right.
Jake:先到机场
Jake: First get to the airport.
Jack: 是给航空公司捐钱的
Jack: It's like donating to the airline.
Jake:那不是
Jake: No, it's not.
Jack: 你当天晚上很贵的
Jack: You'll pay a lot that night.
Jake:我我省钱啊
Jake: I'll save money.
Jake:你不知道啊
Jake: You don't know?
Jake:没跟你讲过
Jake: I never told you?
Lucia:哈哈哈哈你错过了很精彩的故事
Lucia: Hahaha, you missed a really great story.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:因为通常如
Jake: Because usually...
Jake:果我提前买的话赶不上飞机
Jake: If I buy tickets in advance, I miss the flight.
Jake:赶不上飞机
Jake: Miss the flight.
Jake:我通常我提前买赶不上飞机
Jake: I usually miss the flight if I buy tickets in advance.
Jake:对就会误点
Jake: Yeah, I end up being late.
Jake:就坐不上飞机
Jake: And miss the flight.
Jake:然后要退票或者不给退的话也很麻烦
Jake: Then I have to refund the ticket, and if they don't refund, it's a hassle.
Jake:所以就比较浪费钱
Jake: So it's a waste of money.
Jack: 那你为什么不提前买好
Jack: Then why don't you buy in advance?
Jake:就是提前买好的
Jake: I do buy in advance.
Jack: 提前买好一个你能赶上的飞
Jack: Buy in advance for a flight you can catch.
Jake:那很难
Jake: That's hard.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Lucia:你看所有人听到都觉得不可思议
Lucia: You see, everyone thinks it's unbelievable.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha:他永远提前买好赶不上车
Tasha: He always buys in advance and misses the train.
Tasha:这是很让人感觉很奇怪的事情
Tasha: It's a really strange thing.
Jake:哎呀到了到了到了到了
Jake: Oh, we’re here, we’re here.
Tasha:下一场最近的时候是什么时候啊
Tasha: When's the next show?
Lucia:这个我也会不过
Lucia: I can do that too, but...
Jake:这个无所谓这个无所谓
Jake: It doesn't matter, it doesn't matter.
Lucia:每次都是先到那再看看哪一场
Lucia: I always check the showtime when I get there.
Jack: 电影票的价钱是一样的
Jack: The price of movie tickets is the same.
Jack: 机票会贵很多的
Jack: Plane tickets are much more expensive.
Jake:也也没有贵很多的
Jake: Not really that much more.
Jake:我发现
Jake: I found...
Jake:没有没有花很多
Jake: It didn't cost much.
Jack: 哎刘帅现在开的车是从哪
Jack: Hey, where's Choiszt's car from?
Jack: 还是租的车
Jack: Is it rented?
Jake:不是自己的车
Jake: It's not his own car.
Jake:8841啊这个
Jake: 8841, huh?
Jake:我刚看了半天那车我靠
Jake: I was looking at that car for a while, wow.
Jake:哈哈请请请
Jake: Haha, please, please.
Tasha:啊这就到了
Tasha: Ah, we're here.
Lucia:谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Thank you, thank you.
Jake:关
Jake: Close.
Jake:可以我们不知道
Jake: Okay, we don't know.
Jake:禁止左转哈哈哈
Jake: No left turn allowed, hahaha.
Tasha:那我们要去哪里
Tasha: So where do we go now?
Jake:跳过跳过
Jake: Skip it, skip it.
Jake:这里跳过这里
Jake: Skip this part here.
Lucia:我现在真的有点PTSD
Lucia: I really have a bit of PTSD right now.
Jake:啊有有有
Jake: Ah, yes, yes, yes.
Jake:谢云茹他这边有这个修
Jake: Xie Yunru has this repair thing here.
Jake:叫什么回收旧的电器
Jake: What's it called? Recycling old appliances.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha:为什么要喊他
Tasha: Why call him?
Jake:因为他明天把琴带过来了
Jake: Because he's bringing the instrument over tomorrow.
Tasha:他把琴带过来
Tasha: He's bringing the instrument over?
Lucia:然后我们说他怎么拿回去
Lucia: And then we asked how he'll take it back.
Lucia:他说当二手直接在这卖了
Lucia: He said he'll sell it as second-hand here.
Lucia:sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia:哈哈对不起我现在真的有点ptst
Lucia: Haha, sorry, I really have a bit of PTSD right now.
Lucia:因为那个好近然后
Lucia: Because that was so close and...
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Jake:但是一般恶犬那种叫的人不会
Jake: But usually those fierce dogs won't bite.
Jake:不会咬你那小狗
Jake: They won't bite you, those little dogs.
Lucia:内有恶犬
Lucia: Beware of fierce dogs.
Jake:它就它呆它包里
Jake: It just stays in its own bag.
Lucia:对那个小狗只是个无心之师
Lucia: Yes, that little dog is just an innocent bystander.
Jake:哎忍耐们还是记不住密码看起来
Jake: Ah, you guys still can't remember the password, it seems.
Jake:嘿嘿
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:密码多少
Jake: What's the password?
Jake:哈哈哈玩球
Jake: Hahaha, playing ball.
Lucia:要我帮你拿一个吗
Lucia: Do you want me to grab one for you?
Jake:不哎可以你要不拿这个吧
Jake: No, it's okay. Unless you want to take this one.
Lucia:都行都行
Lucia: Either way is fine.
Jake:那那拆一个
Jake: Then, open one up.
Lucia:那我拆了
Lucia: Then I'll open it.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:我们三个分了吧要不
Jake: How about we split it among the three of us?
Lucia:哈哈哈可以可以
Lucia: Hahaha, sure, sure.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:盛情难却
Lucia: Hard to refuse.
Tasha:我们三个人的瓜分史还少吗
Tasha: Haven't we split enough things among the three of us already?
Jake:哈哈哈哈芒果还剩一个
Jake: Hahahaha, there's one mango left.
Lucia:芒果还剩一个都不够
Lucia: One mango left isn't enough.
Lucia:咱仨瓜分的哈哈
Lucia: We split it among the three of us, haha.
Lucia:哎你今天转化的那个呢
Lucia: Hey, what about the one you transformed today?
Jake:咱没称因为我全给转化了
Jake: I didn't weigh it because I transformed all of it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈转化到肚子里了是吗
Lucia: Haha, transformed into your stomach, right?
Jake:全被我转化了
Jake: I transformed all of it.
Lucia:行
Lucia: Got it.
Jake:我们来兑一兑旺仔牛奶牛牛舌
Jake: Let's mix some Wangzai milk and cow tongue.
Jake:维他维他他买了吗
Jake: Did he buy the Vita, Vita?
Lucia:好像没有
Lucia: Seems like he didn't.
Jake:白玉田蓝莓草莓
Jake: Bai Yutian blueberry, strawberry.
Lucia:百利甜也没看着
Lucia: Didn't see Baileys either.
Jake:这这什么字啊
Jake: What does this say?
Jake:草莓后面青提
Jake: After strawberry, green grapes.
Jake:榴莲
Jake: Durian.
Lucia:看成定投了
Lucia: I read it as fixed investment.
Jake:看成定投
Jake: Read it as fixed investment.
Lucia:对不起看成了定投
Lucia: Sorry, I read it as fixed investment.
Jake:哈哈哈什么动作
Jake: Hahaha, what a move.
Jake:定投
Jake: Fixed investment.
Lucia:是一个金融术语
Lucia: It's a financial term.
Jake:定投定投
Jake: Fixed investment, fixed investment.
Jake:好吧定投
Jake: Alright, fixed investment.
Jake:我懂了哈哈
Jake: I get it, haha.
Lucia:哈哈哈打扰了
Lucia: Haha, sorry to bother you.
Choiszt: 那你怎么配对
Choiszt: So how do you pair them?
Choiszt: 比如三三座啊
Choiszt: For example, three-three positions.
Alice:但是100又又又凌乱了
Alice: But 100 is messy again.
Alice:有没有觉得这个家有什么区别
Alice: Don't you feel there's a difference in this home?
Jake:有有有请请请
Jake: Yes, yes, please, please.
Jake:您嗑瓜子请呵呵
Jake: Have some sunflower seeds, please.
Lucia:特别有区别
Lucia: There's definitely a difference.
Lucia:请请请您吃
Lucia: Please, please, have some.
Jake:请您吃他他他他不吃这个他
Jake: Please have some, he, he, he doesn't eat this.
Jake:那他得吃
Jake: But he has to eat.
Jake:旺仔也不对
Jake: Wangzai is not right either.
Jake:也不也不喝
Jake: He doesn't drink it either.
Lucia:喝喝喝来来来杯茶
Lucia: Drink, drink, drink, have some tea.
Jake:茶可以喝对吧
Jake: Tea is drinkable, right?
Jake:茶可以喝
Jake: Tea is drinkable.
Jack: 因为一整个公众号的信息就是
Jack: Because the whole public account information is just
Alice:现在只有就剩刷的东西没有弄了
Alice: Now there's only the scrubbing left to do
Jake:好我们来刷
Jake: Alright, let's scrub
Alice:还有楼上的桌子
Alice: And the tables upstairs
Alice:什么也擦了
Alice: They've all been wiped
Jake:我们也擦
Jake: We'll wipe them too
Alice:然后也只剩刷了
Alice: Then there's only scrubbing left
Jake:我们开摄像头
Jake: Let's turn on the cameras
Jack: 开摄像头啊
Jack: Turn on the cameras, huh
Jake:大家先休息一下
Jake: Everyone take a break
Jake:不要工作
Jake: No working
其他人：这个去哪了啊啊
Others: Where did this go?
Jake:这个不要了
Jake: We don't need this
Jake:这个放后面了
Jake: Put this at the back
Tasha:那这个眼镜就关掉了啊
Tasha: So should I turn off these glasses?
Jake:呃关关关
Jake: Yeah, turn them off
Jake:倒一批
Jake: Pour a batch